- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians.
Hello, Rosie.
Hello, Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] Today, all three of us
are gonna be talking
about parallel structure.
And I've always had trouble
spelling the word parallel,
but Rosie pointed out something
just before we started recording
that is blowing my mind.
Rosie, how do you spell parallel?
- [Voiceover] Well, it's
fun because the two ls
that are together in the word are together
in the middle of the word.
- [Voiceover] Look at
that, they're parallel!
That's all.
- [Voiceover] It's fun.
- [Voiceover] That's just, that's amazing.
Parallel structure is less
a consideration of grammar,
it's really more about style, right.
Parallel structure basically
means that when you're making
some kind of list in a sentence,
if you're using a series of verbs
or if you're using a series
of nouns, any series of words,
they should all roughly
line up with one another.
So let's say I was an outdoorsman
and I said, "I love fishing,
skiing and rock climbing."
Now each one of these is a gerund, right,
it the ing form of a verb
we're using as a noun.
And this sentence exhibits
parallel structure,
but, you know, sometimes
you'll see a sentence
that'll mess that up, right?
So let's say you were editing
someone's personal statement,
an athlete's personal
statement and they said,
"I love fishing, skiing,
and to climb rocks."
Now, there's nothing
grammatically incorrect
about this sentence, it makes sense,
it is legal in the way
that it is composed,
but stylistically, it
just doesn't harmonize.
So this is not parallel, but this is.
- [Voiceover] Some other
things to look out for
to make sure you're
making a sentence parallel
is if everything is active
voice or passive voice,
infinitive verbs versus
other forms of verbs,
like to eat versus eating,
and a string of individual
modifiers like adjectives
versus larger phrases.
- [Voiceover] Let's put that into action.
Okay, so active versus passive voice.
- [Voiceover] So an example
if we're not gonna have
parallel structure would be something like
the cake was baked, frosted,
and I put sprinkles on it.
- [Voiceover] So what we're saying here is
that here is a passive thing
that happened to the cake,
the cake was baked.
Here's another passive thing
that happens to the cake,
the cake was frosted by someone else.
And then that someone else
comes in and Paige says,
"I put sprinkles on it."
But, if we're going to assume
that sprinkled is now a verb
that means to be covered
in sugary cake decorations,
we would say the cake was
baked, frosted, and sprinkled,
or decorated with sprinkles,
but I kind of like sprinkled.
So that's active versus passive.
We've already covered infinitive
versus other verb forms,
so that's, you know, skiing,
well, that's to ski versus skiing,
so this is what we call
an infinitive form,
and this is another form
that's called a gerund.
So make sure to keep those
separate in your lists.
And then lists of individual
terms versus longer phrases.
So if you are describing something
with a string of adjectives,
be careful when you follow
it up with a longer phrase.
- [Voiceover] For
example, sharks are large,
damp, and dangerous.
Those are all just short,
individual modifiers,
as opposed to sharks are large, damp,
and not to be trifled with.
- [Voiceover] And look,
again, we're not saying
this is not a grammatical sentence.
It is.
And sometimes you may want
to break parallel structure
in order to have some
sort of particular effect.
If you are trying to draw
attention to this last element,
then, yeah, you might want
to break parallel structure,
but we want to make you aware
that there is just a sort
of general tendency towards
making your sentences
harmonious in this way.
Baked, frosted and sprinkled,
large, damp, and dangerous,
you know, and then when
you want to have access
to that ability, to really draw attention
to that last element, then you can say,
"Oh, you know what?
"I'm gonna make this perpendicular."
(girls chuckle)
Now, is perpendicularity,
is that a thing that I
just made up right now?
Yes.
Are we going with it?
Maybe.
(girls chuckle)
- [Voiceover] Yeah, I like it.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] It's not parallel.
- [Voiceover] Well, I suppose
that just about covers parallel structure.
So, for one last time with Paige,
you can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Rosie out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.
- [Voiceover] You've
been a wonderful intern,
Paige, we'll miss you.
- [Voiceover] We'll miss you.
- [Voiceover] Thank
you, I'll miss you, too.